hello everyone welcome to the mindscape
podcast i'm your host john carroll
and like many of the guests here on
mindscape i am fortunate enough to have
a wikipedia page
about myself i mean it's not that i have
it because i didn't make it or edit it
but it's there you can go to wikipedia
and for some reason uh recently i did go
to it i don't even visit it
that often um and i don't edit it myself
so i was interested to see that most of
my wikipedia page
is about religion and atheism uh not all
of it it does talk about my research a
little bit
but a lot of it is about you know my
philosophical religious views
uh the debates that i've had about
religion and things like that
which is interesting to me because in my
self-conception
uh it's perfectly fair you know i am an
atheist i've talked about it a lot no
question about that
but it's still a small part relatively
speaking of who i am and what i do
but it speaks to the fact that people
are interested
right that these are issues that matter
to people you know physics is there but
the religion
or the atheism that's what's really
important uh and it's it's not wrong
to be interested in these issues the
nature of the universe
includes the question of whether or not
it is mostly a naturalistic universe
or some kind of theistic or spiritual or
beyond naturalistic universe in some
sense
so i've long wanted to have you know
more conversations here on mindscape
about those issues and we've touched on
it before you know we had jeremy england
who is a physicist
uh but who's also religious and we had
people like mark de villiers who talked
about the history of
hell in an extremely amusing podcast
that that i
recommend that you listen to if you
haven't already but i wanted to get a
religious person on to talk about
religion and so today's guest
reza oslon is a great person to do
exactly that
now people who are classified or
self-classify as religious or
faithful or believers come in a lot of
different varieties right so just saying
someone is religious almost doesn't tell
you that much about them
um there are people who are very
hardcore and also
very almost anthropomorphic about it you
know they think that god is a person
up there judging them making the
decisions deciding right from wrong
and there are people whose versions of
religion are not that anthropomorphic
are
closer to something ineffable and
transcendent and
quasi-philosophical so reza is an
interesting person for
his personal journey he was born into a
muslim family converted to christianity
at some point and then converted back
into islam so he currently calls himself
muslim but he also if you
as we are going to find out listening to
the podcast his views are
what you might call pantheistic right
they're something that
uh god is not a person up there in the
sky judging us
but god is a feature of the universe
that is sort of transcendent
and above the natural order of things
very important
and then you know he's he's willing to
admit to to be honest about his feelings
about how this
impacts the physical behavior of the
universe there are some people who want
to say
god is just a way of talking about the
universe but the universe obeys the laws
of physics
reza says nope there are people and
other biological organisms and things
like that don't exactly obey the laws of
physics because there is this
spiritual side to things that does
intervene so
we talk about that we talk about what it
might mean and you know as always on the
podcast i'm here to
um listen to the person that i have as a
guest and let them give their best
possible case for their views
while inserting my own opinions here and
there so you'll
hear me do that so this is i think a
very you know
reasonable discussion about two slightly
different world
views um we don't get into
theism versus anti-theism right we're
i'm not trying to bash religion you know
there's a whole
discourse about whether or not religion
is good or bad in the world
and that's an interesting and important
discourse but it's separate in my mind
from the discourse about whether
religion is true or not and as i've
often said
the question of whether religion is true
or not is infinitely easier
to me than the question of whether
religion has been an overall good for
the world which is a messy complicated
thing so we don't talk about
it that much this is much more
philosophical um scientific kind of
discussion
than that so hopefully it will be
interesting even though
pragmatically in some ways we're not
that far apart and if this kind of thing
is up your alley and you want more uh
reza has actually teamed up with
rain wilson the actor known as dwight on
the office and other places
to start their own podcast called
metaphysical milkshakes so they're going
to be
talking about the meaning of life
existential questions of the universe
with various people
different persuasions so you can get
more conversations with reza and rayne
etc if you go to wherever fine
podcasters hold metaphysical milkshake
the other thing this is very far apart
this is a giant leap in subject but i
want to announce
that after some requests from various
listeners we have a
merchandise store associated with
mindscape now you can go to
t public t-e-e-p-u-b-l-i-c-t public dot
com
uh search for my name or even better
just go to the mindscape homepage
preposterousuniverse.com podcast in the
right hand
column you'll see a link to t-shirts
mugs and more
so you can get t-shirts now that say
mindscape on them
um and there's different designs there's
a schrodinger's cat awake plus a sleep
there's the core theory equation right
with all those greek letters and so
forth
there's a little graph of complexity and
entropy changing over time
you can get these on t-shirts on mugs on
stickers for your computer whatever you
want
masks right if you want to have a mask
with the core theory equation on it here
is your chance so um it's a it's a tiny
bit of money for me
honestly it was not worth the hourly
rate let's put it that way i'm not
really in it for the money
but um hopefully some people can have
cute little t-shirts that remind them of
the fun times they've had
listening to mindscape and with that
let's go
podcast hey thanks for having me sean
i'm glad to be here
so let me start with like the most
obvious question the question that is uh
pushing us here uh you started a podcast
you've begun a podcast why in the role
would you do that
doesn't the world have enough podcasts
what what is it that you like
i wanna i want i want in on that sweet
sweet podcast
cash yeah you know good it's just come
to the right
all those bucks you know what i'm saying
how do you know what to do
literally hundreds of dollars dozens of
dollars will come your way
due to this effort you're putting in i'm
pretty sure i just started a t-shirt
store
you know that people have been asking me
about that for a long time when are you
going to get like merchandise and so i
finally started that
not smart we got it we haven't we
haven't gotten to the merch yet yeah
on metaphysical milkshake but uh you
know this podcast kind of started
my friend the actor rayne wilson and i
have been friends for
um a while and people you know obviously
know reign as dwight
on on the office uh this kind of iconic
character that he created but what
people don't really know about him is
that he is a
deeply philosophical uh very
um spiritual man uh
you know he writes and thinks a lot
about
you know the questions of the human
condition who are we why are we here
what are we supposed to do is there free
will
what happens when we die you know these
are the things that kind of animate him
and
the the kind of questions that have
always animated me and so
he and i would get together you know
sometimes have breakfast have lunch and
have these kind of
deep conversations about life's big
questions
and you know one day we were having
breakfast and talking about the meaning
of life and
and then i think one of us just kind of
said you know
we should maybe record this stuff and
maybe people will want to hear it and
that's how metaphysical milkshake was
born we basically
every week is one kind of life's big
question
you know and we discuss it ourselves and
then we usually bring on some kind of
expert to
to help us figure things out well i
think a lot of interestingly you know
despite the fact that we dress it up in
um robes of rationality and trying to
think through this sophisticated way
a lot of times the attitude people that
people bring to these kinds of questions
is driven by their personality
uh just as much as it is by facts and
reason and logic and things like that
uh and so there is a personality that's
kind of like let's all just get along
aren't we all saying the same thing
let's just ask questions there's another
kind of personalities like
here's the answer you should believe me
so
which side of this personality divide
you coming down on
definitely closer to the here's the
answer
part okay uh out of those two i mean you
know the thing about rayne is that
he's such a sweet guy and he's exactly
who you were talking about but we're all
the same we're all pink on the inside
let's reach across the aisle let's make
common cause
you know let's find out the things that
we have in common and
i am much more uh there are
certain things that are right and there
are certain things that are wrong
there are certain things that are good
and there are certain things that are
evil and i don't give a [ __ ] about
reaching across the aisle
to evil like if you are somebody who
refuses to acknowledge my basic humanity
my response to you excuse me is go [ __ ]
yourself
not let me let me reach across the aisle
and figure out
why you think that i should go back to
my country
um so you know ray and i we we have the
same world view in the sense that you
know we see things through a spiritual
lens
we are driven by a desire to experience
transcendence in in different forms but
we have different personalities for sure
and
it comes across on the in the podcast a
lot where i'm
i'm much more cynical and i'm much more
uh
let's just say dark than he is so you
will learn as
a new podcaster that there's a little
button when you publish each episode for
clean versus explicit so don't worry
we're explicit for this one that's okay
no no sorry guys listen
one thing you should know about me is
that i
really really like to cuss i i enjoy
swear words as a writer as a thinker
as someone who loves words i love
swear words and i use them with pride
i'm not sure what god thinks about that
but i'm glad that uh you're explicit
about it so
i like the sort of good cop bad cop uh
you know buddy act that you're bringing
then to the podcast but then
it opens up uh the next question which
is so we have set the stage a little bit
how would you characterize your own
personal views about these questions i
know that probably there's a lot
uh it would require more than a few
sentences but like how should we think
about your perspective here
you know i think rayne and i this is the
thing that brought us together is that
we refuse the sort of
simple dichotomy uh
between sort of science and religion
spirituality and and reason you know
those those are false dichotomies
they're they're false categories as far
as we're concerned
um we uh are both
deeply spiritual but we're also deeply
scientific in our outlook and we don't
really find that much of a conflict
between those two views i mean certainly
there are
ways in which both of those views can be
stretched to the extreme
i mean in terms of religion it's obvious
in terms of science unfortunately for
some reason most people
think that science is some kind of
neutral force in the world for good
and in many ways it is as a methodology
that's certainly true but science can
very quickly become scientism
and scientism the the belief that
science has an answer for every issue
the belief that indeed science should
actually
replace religion uh i think
is uh not just wrongheaded but i think
uh
it can be a deeply dangerous way of
manipulating science
as an ideology instead of as what it
truly is which is a methodology
well i will uh encourage listeners who
haven't already done so to go back and
listen to my podcast with alex rosenberg
who is the most happy uh explicit
scientific advocate that i know like he
has taken up
to reclaim the word scientism as a good
thing so that that
that would be uh a different point of
view but i would i would
i would disagree but i'd love to i'd
love to yeah that's why we hear that
but okay that's good as a sort of an
attitudinal uh perspective you're coming
from but i
i kind of want to know the answer to the
basic you know
ontological questions about the world do
you believe in god do you believe in
afterlife
do you believe uh that there are
objective moral rules out there
like the usual things that come along
with
a religious belief system a spiritual
belief system
yeah um let's start from the ground
right and let's let's unders let's get
our terminology correct so
religion and faith are two different
things
okay uh faith is individual
it's ineffable faith
as all the sort of the the best sort of
cognitive studies of it um go is
deeply embedded in our cognitive
processes it is an
evolutionary impulse this is the the
subject of my most previous book which
is called god a human history and it's
all about
the idea that what we reach what we
think of
as the religious impulse is
a part of our evolutionary process
um and there are many uh
you know ideas about why it's part of
our evolutionary process but what there
is no question about what there is no
more debate about
is that it is an inextricable part
of the human condition indeed it's a
part of the human condition that
actually
the archaeological evidence is as clear
as it gets that it actually
predates homo sapiens it's a
it's a biological impulse that we see
in neanderthals it we have
ample evidence of it in the neanderthal
burial sites
neanderthal um uh
caves uh in which we have what is
unquestionable uh ritual
um the the detritus of ritual experience
let's put it that way
and we even have some far less
certain um archaeological evidence of
that impulse
in even earlier forms of humans
but that's different than religion
religion is merely the
language the systemic highly controlled
uh language through which we
express this
faith impulse this impulse that is
embedded in our cognitive processes
that is part of what it means to be
human so
yes you could say that i have a religion
but my religion
is merely the language the framework
of metaphors and symbols that i use to
communicate to myself
and to like-minded people the
inexpressible
experience of transcendence
so that's the first thing that i would
say so i'm a person of faith
and if you would say well how do you
express your faith i would say
okay i would express it through uh the
religion
of islam because it's the language that
i that i like the most it's the one that
i'm most familiar with
but to the question can i do you believe
in god
yeah i know i want to know whether you
believe in god or not but you but you've
said too many juicy things that i need
to just like
i want to expand a little bit um we have
time to dig in here
uh i'm always a little bit curious when
people talk about this evolutionary
uh impulse towards faith or belief in
transcendence or something like that
uh number one i'm skeptical that it's
true
because i can imagine that it's an
evolutionary adaptation for
something else that is sometimes
expressed as
faith or religion rather than directly
that um
but even number two it doesn't seem to
be inextricable to me
as some of us have extracted it pretty
effectively
and and but i don't want to talk about
either one of those things what i want
to talk about is
um you know in moral and ethical
philosophy there's a whole
set of arguments called evolutionary or
genealogical debunking arguments
where they say it's an argument against
moral objectivity
and the argument goes look clearly like
as you say we evolve you know we have
pressures to survive uh that give us
certain instincts certain impulses
but the impulses that we get from
evolution are chosen for their survival
value or for their you know reproductive
fitness
not for their truth not for being
correct
so once you say that there's this
impulse driven to us
given to us by evolution for this that
undermines the idea that this thing is
true like you're sort of opening up
here's the thing but here's what's
important is that morality has
literally nothing to do whatsoever
with the religious impulse at all in
fact what most people talk about when
they talk about religiously inspired
morality
is barely 5 000 years old
and the religious impulse conservatively
is at least 200 000 years old that we
have material evidence
showing proof of religious of the
religious or what i'm calling the
religious impulse
that goes back at least 200 000 years if
not more
um so that's why the argument of oh well
you know the reason that we have the
religious impulse is that it you know
helps
us be moral people it keeps me from
stabbing you know the caveman
in the chest next to me and eating all
of his food no it doesn't
no that's not at all what religion was
about it never was
until about five thousand a year the
very concept of a divine law giver
of a divine law giver of a moral concept
of religion
is a brand new idea the gods of greece
were as immoral as it gets the gods of
mesopotamia
were not just amoral they were immoral
um so by no means that that is a very
people who make that argument are making
a very unsophisticated argument but
you're you're absolutely right
in that the problem with
the what i would say you know a fairly
accepted proposition that whatever the
religious impulse is
it is a product of our evolutionary
processes our cognitive processes has to
do with the fact that it is
universal and uh and it
as i say it goes back to even before uh
homo homo sapiens as arose as a species
now the question is why and you
said it very smartly the consensus view
of those cognitive scientists those
cognitive theorists of religion who have
studied this
is that because there is literally no
adaptive advantage whatsoever for the
religious impulse i mean
none if anything in terms of
the material resources that it requires
the energy
that it requires the anxiety that it
produces
it's the opposite of an adaptive
advantage
um so then why the consensus view
seems to be that it is
the in the unintended result
of some other evolutionary
uh some other adaptive advantage and
there are
two primary candidates for this
one is the theory of mind which most
people are familiar with the theory of
mind is that thing that makes you
realize that
the thing that looks like you feels like
you it's an you know
it helps you create empathy and all that
stuff and then of course there's the
there's what's often referred to as the
the had or the
hyperactive agency detection device it's
that thing that makes us think that
every
knock uh that happens you know in your
house
is caused by someone doing the knocking
and the
sort of the the prevailing theory is
that when you when you combine those two
evolutionary processes that have very
clear adaptive advantages
the unintended echo of that is the
universal because that's that part's
unquestioned
the universal impulse towards
um religious belief that's a perfectly
fine
answer i don't question that answer um
but so so just to be clear you know i
was actually not
uh in any way making an argument that
religion evolved because of morality i
was merely making an analogy
between the structures of two arguments
one says
your your beliefs and moral objective
truths
are ungrounded because it would be too
weird for those to be the same moral
objective
moral truths that were given to us by
relit by evolution
i'm having trouble getting the sentence
out likewise analogously
if you say that there is a religious
impulse given to us by evolution
uh it makes it highly unlikely that your
religious
uh beliefs about the world that you get
from that or that you associate with
that are true
true because they're not okay good yeah
so the religious ideologies that arise
from this universal impulse
are nothing more than man-made
frameworks
i use the analogy of language because it
just helps people
think better right they're they're
man-made frameworks that help
to in obvious ways control
but also to um make
sense of what is a universal impulse
right right um the impulse is there the
the the decision to not believe is an
active decision but the the belief
impulse you're born with
for reasons again that may have nothing
to do
with the actual belief itself
um but or that's just a kind of a
byproduct an accidental byproduct of
some other
you know impulse that we have but
nevertheless it's there it has to be
unlearned so let me let me give you the
chance to tell
our audience whether or not you believe
in god yeah so this is what i was going
to say
any any time anyone ever
asks you the question do you believe in
god the
only legitimate answer is what do you
mean by god
this is the this word god is such a
it cracks me up it is probably the word
that people assume we all share most in
common the definition of most in common
and yet it is unquestionably the most
variable word
in the english language because what you
say god may mean something completely
different than what i mean when i say
the word god
so if you say do you believe in god i
have to say well what do you mean by god
okay let me that's perfectly fine i
completely agree that it is uh
entirely an ill-defined concept is there
anything that you believe in as part of
the fundamental architecture of the
world
that you are comfortable associating
with the word god
yes so my conception
of god whatever god is and and this is
very much you know born from my own
personal experience but it is a part of
i'm gonna
i'm gonna rely because we have no choice
i'm gonna rely
on the language that i have available to
me
this kind of ready-made pre-packaged
language
that is given to me offered to me by the
religion of islam but in this particular
case very
much more specifically the sufi
tradition within the islam within islam
which is kind of the mystical tradition
within islam my conception of god is
as pure uh necessary
existence and so
my view of god is not not like
a lot of other views of god my god is
not anthropomorphic
my god has no human qualities or human
attributes whatsoever
my god is pure existence but
as pure existence and this is where
sufism kind of comes in
as pure existence that means that sort
of just logically speaking
nothing can exist that isn't god
nothing can exist outside of the thing
that is pure existence
and so i am what is often referred to uh
as a pantheist i believe that all things
are god that god is all things and all
things is god that nothing can exist
except in so far as it shares in the
only thing that
exists and so that pantheism which
in in my the book that i was mentioning
um my book god of human history
is the earliest form of spirituality is
the kind of spirituality that i ascribe
to
now but do i think that god has
a will a plan a purpose these are
human terms they don't belong to god
do i think god is good or evil that's a
human construct yeah
if you've always said you wanted to read
more this summer is yours for the taking
empower your inner reader with literati
book clubs
where you can read alongside the world's
most inspiring authors and leaders join
malala
stephen curry richard branson and more
on their next reading adventure
literati delivers the monthly book picks
straight to your door
so you can spend less time finding a
good book and more time actually reading
one
whether you're enjoying beach reads with
ellen hildebrand or exploring mythic
realms with joseph campbell scholars
you'll find their brilliant insights on
the literati app
authors leaders and activists spark
lively conversations in 12
different unique book clubs engaging a
diverse community of readers from all
around the world
that means you can talk about steph
curry's favorite books
with steph curry the real person
reimagine what a book club can be
redeem your free trial at literati.com
mindscape that's l-i-t-e-r-a-t-i
dot com slash mindscape to learn more
and read more with literati
it i think it's fair then to sort of um
flip it around turn god off for the
moment
and think about i don't want to use too
much technological uh
technical philosophical terms but the
ontology of the world is a word i
already used what the word
world is made of fundamentally and in
the philosophy literature again we
we separate out naturalists versus
non-naturalists so naturalists think
there's the only the natural world and
non-naturalists think there's something
extra and uh
naturalists have difficulty wondering
what that would be but it's still the
majority of people on earth who believe
in it
and then within naturalists there are
physicalists people who believe that
there's just the physical world and
there are other people who think that
the world has other properties like
maybe mental properties
consciousness something like that so
within that tripartite distinction of
physicalists
naturalist non-physicalists
non-naturalists do you have a
comfortable home in either one of those
three
well so i think if i were to be
if i were to be honest about the way
that i approach my
spirituality and my experience of the
world
it has to do with that word that i used
earlier which is
transcendence i am not a physicalist i'm
not a materialist
you know i do not believe that the only
thing the only reality is that reality
which i can empirically experience
okay i think that that is a profoundly
arrogant
and strangely anthropocentric uh you
know view
of what reality is i do believe
that there is a fundamental reality that
lies beyond the material realm
and i believe that that reality
um can be experienced
that we have the ability it's not
some kind of magical you know
i i hate to use the word spiritual
because then people immediately think
that i'm talking about magical thinking
i believe that whatever the religious
impulse is
it is a process of electrical currents
in my brain i believe that
my brain is chemically
created to have a spiritual experience
and so i believe that the fullness of
the human experience cannot
be contained solely by the material
realm i don't think that the brain is
meant to do that
i think that that realm of transcendence
that which lies beyond is a thing that
every
human being every brain has the natural
capacity to experience
and indeed the experience of it is
the fullness of of what it means to be
human
so that's why i'm a spiritual being
that's why i long for spirituality
not because i think it's outside of of
the material
but i think it's because it is or
outside of you know reality i should say
good um because it is separate from the
material
material yeah that was the wrong yeah um
but because i believe that
it is a natural function
of my brain that i should
take advantage of in order to fully
uh realize what it is to be human
good that that part is very clarifying i
like that i'm going to ask you two more
clarifying questions before you can
back up and sort of justify some of the
claims all right
is there any sense that you believe in
something along the lines of life after
death
yeah so you know this is a a topic that
you can imagine we deal with a lot i'm
not a physical milkshake
it is the ultimate metaphysical there
you go yes
question um plugging the podcast
excellent this is not your first video
you know you gotta always kind of bring
it up
apple podcast please subscribe wherever
you listen to podcasts
um
i believe well
you know let's just take it to its most
basic scientific level right
the fundamental rule
of of science is the preservation of
matter and energy
right so the the notion that whatever
exists
today has always existed
and will always exist as long as the
universe
exists that the collection
you know of matter that has made me who
i
am and that has given me a sense of
consciousness
again i don't believe that consciousness
is some magical thing
that exists i believe that it is the
result
of the matter that has created me
and that matter is eternal
now so that it will always exist once
i'm gone it'll continue
the question is will it continue
still in the form of my consciousness or
not
i that's where my spiritual
views of the afterlife begin right so
that at that point that's where i have
to say to myself
i would like to think that whatever
combination of matter and energy
has created my sense of me
that that sense will
continue almost like as an imprint on
that matter
on that energy and so whatever the
afterlife
is it's that experience of returning
returning to the universe that you know
the matter that is me
goes on to be the matter that is the
universe but that carries with it
again almost like an echo the imprint
of whatever my consciousness was
that's what i like to think is
the afterlife um
but that's obviously a far cry from
either what most religion tells you
because religion wants you to continue
to be
you later on right and i think that's
that's where the trickiness comes
well i think i mean what the difference
is i would put it is that i mean you're
talking about
uh the your existence having this
persistent impact on the world after
you've gone
in some sense but the difference is that
when you're alive
the world can have an impact on you and
you can feel things about it and think
about it and respond to it and feel
happy or sad and
it sounds like you're not accepting the
existence of those things once you die
i mean again i because language is so
limiting when we're talking about these
kinds of things that we we have to rely
i was going to say we have to rely on
metaphor but even when we're not relying
on metaphor we are using metaphor
uh because we have no choice but to talk
about these things in terms of metaphor
but the sufis have this sort of
wonderful notion about
how the way to think about it is is a
drop of water
in an ocean right like you're the drop
of water
and you are dropped in the ocean now do
you still
exist as an entity as a
drop i mean
no no no not really yeah right i mean
pretty clearly no but the drop that was
you
is part of this of this larger ocean
now so the question is is there a part
of the ocean
that is you uh exclusively you
individually you or
is the the moment that you are part of
that the moment that the matter
and energy that is me standing here
talking to you
is now dead and gone and now
slowly absorbing back into the universe
is any of that still
me i wish i i knew the answer to that
question but this is again where the
faith part comes in where it's like
that is what i'm comfortable saying with
with confidence that whatever is me
continues forever
the question is as it's continuing
forever is it still me does it carry
any of me still and that's where
my faith says yes
but that's just pure with the interview
like the way that i think exactly that
reflection yes
yes maybe yeah okay i mean just to be
clear
uh i that that diverges pretty
dramatically from what my understanding
of the
orthodox islamic position would be that
there is a paradise there's a hell
yeah we have a place there's a place
where good people go in a place where
bad people go
it depends on what you did and what you
believed and so you're that's not part
of
your personal version well look those
are again
human attempts to make sense of the
incomprehensible
right christianity has a heaven in hell
islam has a heaven
and hell and i think most people most of
your listeners would probably think that
the concept of heaven and hell is a
is an ancient concept that it's one that
we would find
in most um religions that it's an
early form of religion the concept of
heaven and hell is three thousand years
old it was
invented by a man named zarathustra like
he's the first person who said actually
no there's a good
death and a bad after death and some
good people go to the good place and bad
people go to the bad place that's 3000
years old again
if you even if you take me even remotely
seriously
and and you take my 200 000 year you
know
explanation for you know the origins of
the religious impulse
3000 years a concept of heaven and hell
this is a very new idea so
yes it's true that there are orthodox
conceptions of what happens in the
afterlife
but those orthodox conceptions
are exact exactly that their conceptions
their their ideas for how to think
about the afterlife i will say that
mindscape listeners actually
do know better because we had a
wonderful podcast episode with mark de
villiers who wrote a
biography of hell about all the
different ways in which different
cultures invented this idea of hell and
it was fascinating and hilarious and so
yeah yeah exactly very new idea very new
idea
okay uh then the third question i want
to know we had an ontological question
an afterlife question do you think that
if you do believe
uh in the in the existence of an aspect
of reality that is transcendent or even
spiritual
does that have any impact on our notions
of right and wrong
moral and immoral here on earth yeah
this is a tough one i mean i think
because again it goes back to this
notion
of god as a divine law giver right that
we know in our hearts what is right and
wrong
because we were made that way by a god
who
gives us our laws again if heaven and
hell is 3000 years old the concept of
divine morality is
barely 5 000 years old barely a very new
idea you know that are ancient peoples
did not look to the heavens for the
source of their morality
not to zoos certainly yeah on the
contrary exactly
um and so this comes down to this notion
of
is it that we derive our values
from god and then put them into the
world
or do we derive our values from the
world
and then implant them onto god and i'm
definitely in the latter category
because again going back to
my definition of god morality doesn't
really play a role
in pure existence concepts of right and
wrong
good and evil these are human constructs
that we then try to demonize
by placing in the sort of conception of
of the divine and that by the way that's
why it changes all the time i mean all
you have to do is read the hebrew
scriptures to know that
you know what was okay in one one book
becomes not okay in the next book
you know um so
but that doesn't mean and i think this
is important so usually when i talk like
this
people say oh i get it so you're a
relativist and you know
all that not really no not really
because i do truly believe that the
answer to
is there a right or wrong is there good
and evil
is an answer that rests within us that
part i do believe i just don't think it
was put there by god
you know um and and while
it is a slippery slope it's a very
tricky thing to talk about because
as we say morality is constantly
changing our consensus
over what is moral and what is not is
constantly changing based on the
changing contexts in which we live
but i do think that there is a
fundamental
divide um in
in where moral certitude
can rest and that divide is
does it affirm humanity
or not and so
i can sit here and say i don't believe
that there's any such thing as the devil
i can tell you exactly how the devil was
invented
i don't think there's anything as hell
again you know
you know that all that those are all
just absurdities
but i do think that there is evil i just
don't think evil is a cosmic force
i think that evil is the
proactive removal of
a a person's humanity right
that is where evil lies and so
i can talk with you know
comfort about good and evil without
necessarily having to define those
things
in cosmic terms or for that matter in
absolute terms other than to say
did the denial the degradation
of humanity is morally evil
and the the opposite of that is morally
good
well good so here's where it becomes
operational right um
what you just said about morality is
like 98 overlap with my own
extremely atheist view of morality uh
i wouldn't i would the the two percent
is that i would
almost completely remove the certainty
there
but i do think that morality is
constructed by human beings and there's
a lot of overlap between different
people's
conceptions of what it is so we can
build up some social cohesion
on the basis of that so let's let's dig
into how that relates to
religion in some way i mean nothing that
you said
referred just now to the existence of
this transcendent realm so number one
is there any connection there for you
and number
two um how should we think about the
fact that more traditionally or at least
in more organized religions
uh or among many religious believers
they directly look to religious
instruction for moral instruction
well let's tackle the second part first
because that's it's it's you know basic
and obvious i mean
human beings are driven
towards certainty um
moral certainty philosophical certainty
certainty
is comfortable um
you know again if we want to talk about
uh is this part of our you know
evolutionary
uh uh drive yeah i think so i think that
you know nature is scary the world
is frightening and you need to you know
death
is a is a uncontrolled and
uncontrollable
phenomenon and you need to figure out
how to control it
and you need to figure out how to make
sense of the world
and religion does that very very well by
telling you
what is right and what is wrong what to
do what not to do
and as long as you recognize that those
answers are created by human beings not
by the divine
then you can accept religion as as
precisely what it is you know a a a set
of
moral rules guidance to live by and
religious people
who truly do live by those moral rules
and moral guidances tend to be very nice
and wonderful
and you know good people um
and so that's a that's a separate that's
a separate issue then your
really astute question which is
is there a relationship between this
searching for within oneself for that
concept of moral certitude and
the the what i would say is our
evolutionary
strive for transcendence and it comes
back to
this notion that i was saying about what
does it mean to
live life as a human to its fullest
and i think that's where those two ideas
that i just presented
start to come together in a way i do
believe
that striving for transcendence
using the cognitive processes that you
have
in order to expand your mind and to
experience
things beyond the material realm is
the fullest expression of being human
and i also believe that the
dividing line you know the moral
dividing line is about
what what promotes
humanity and what doesn't right um what
oppresses
humanity so fundamentally
all of it in the end comes down to human
to being human right that that's my my
spiritual longing my spiritual life
is grounded in my experience as a human
that's what i think is important to say
my conception of morality is grounded in
my experience
as a human but because i don't
differentiate
between human and divine because i don't
differentiate
between um you know
god and man or creation and and
creator then that
fundamental desire to be human to its
fullest extent
is a spiritual uh uh
thing for me it's a spiritual uh pursuit
for me in other words i don't i don't
look out there
for god i look in here for god
breakthroughs happen when you bring
great thinkers together
that incredible collision of ideas is
one of the reasons why i do this podcast
if you're trying to create something new
at your company it starts with great
people
and to find them faster you need indeed
indeed is a job site that makes hiring
incredibly simple just attract interview
and hire
with indeed you can do all of your
hiring in one place even the
interviewing
and you don't need to just hope your
perfect candidate will find you
indeed's hiring tools help you cut
through the noise to hire faster and
smarter
indeed instant match provides a list of
quality candidates
whose resumes are on indeed the moment
you post a sponsor job
best of all you only pay for the
applicants who meet your must have
qualifications
so join more than three million
businesses worldwide that use indeed to
hire great
talent fast and you can get started
right now with a 75
sponsored job credit to upgrade your job
post at indeed.com
mindscape that's a 75 credit at
indeed.com mindscape
offer valid through september 30th terms
and conditions apply
now i think i get that but i i it
it's seen i worry that it is
making blurry a distinction that matters
to me so i want to sort of interrogate a
little bit yeah um
you know part of me wants to say that
operationally like like i said we're
not that different in our views on
morality so
how would things change if the language
you use
as you say you like to say that uh
religion is kind of a language that we
use to interpret the world
what if we dropped all the religious
part from that language what if we were
physicalists what if we
said like yeah i'm a bunch of atoms i
obey the laws of physics
once i become a complex collective
creature i don't know what all my atoms
are doing so it makes more sense to
think of me as
an agent that has desires and goals and
makes choices
and and wants certain things to happen
and and that's the world that's the
world we have evidence for and we live
in and we can be happy with that i mean
how does my life change if i say that
versus adding on to it
this other aspect of reality that is not
captured by physicalism
well i think in order to truly answer
that question we need to have a far more
expansive
definition of what religion actually is
and what it does
you know i think when the problem is is
that
when people think of religion they think
of god
that they as far as most people go those
things go hand in hand
when about half the world's religions
don't have a god don't have any
conception
of a god and yet they're still we still
call them religion
right i mean theravada buddhism there's
no god in theravada buddhism
there's no god in jainism these are you
know
these are strict ancient religions
so then the question is okay well then
what the hell is a religion
then is it about ritual behavior
that's not such a bad definition of
religion
ceremonial communal ceremonial
ritual behavior but if that's your
definition of religion then a football
game
is religion right all right uh okay
so let's remove the ritual aspect of it
for a moment and let's go with what what
you know reza is talking about which is
sort of the striving for
transcendence maybe that's what religion
is okay
well then i guess mountain climbing is a
religion
then because a lot of you know mountain
climbers i know do it because it's a
experience of transcendence for them
so what the hell is religion then
i would say i would argue that
religion is if you really break it down
in all those ways
it's just another kind of ideology
religion as an ideology isn't
all that different from other ideologies
from patriotism
from nationalism from communism you know
um the difference people always say is
oh but religion
religion is established itself
on moral absolutism right
and so that's what makes religion
different as an ideology really
i mean i don't know about the patriots
that you know about
but the patriots that i know about
would there's nothing that you can say
or do that would ever change their mind
that america is the greatest country in
the history of the world
right which is [ __ ] in
a thousand different ways but it's not
about
you know um evidence it's about a belief
system
i would say that atheism a lot of forms
of atheism
is just another kind of belief system it
is predicated on a set of propositions
most of them unprovable about the
workings of the universe
um now if we
think of religion in those terms
then what we recognize very quickly
is that religion in and of itself
isn't a force of good or bad
it isn't it doesn't promote peace or
violence
it isn't about compassion or
you know hatred religion is in many ways
a
neutral ideology that the meaning of
which
is described solely by the believer him
or herself
religion is what the religious person
says it is
right right but i'm completely on board
with all of those things that you just
said
uh and i kind of don't care but i'm not
right honest i'm gonna be honest with
you i forgot the question i was right
exactly so
waxing on and on about terminology like
we like we annoying professors do
uh forget the word religion um and i
forget all the
sort of bad versions of either
theism or atheism for that matter um
i want to get home in on your version
pantheism transcendence an element that
goes beyond the material to the world
and i want to know boots on the ground
how does it affect my life
uh how does it how do i end up in a
different place
where i to believe that view of the
ontology of the world
than if i were a strict materialist who
just said yeah you know a bunch of atoms
obeying the laws of physics
well at the risk of kind of repeating
something that i had said already
if it's because that is what human
beings
are designed to do human beings are
designed the brain our cognitive
processes
are designed for transcendence
they're designed to
experience things beyond the material
realm so that's just
to me if you would say why would i do
that i would say
because that's the human experience in
its fullest sense
but if what you're saying is okay but
why would i use why would i
rely on a religion for any of that
okay like okay if you're saying okay
maybe i accept your view
that transcendence is the natural
you know uh uh human condition that's
striving for transcendence fine
but what you know why would i have to do
it under any kind of religious
uh umbrella well i mean i'm sorry not to
short-circuit you but that's
that is i'm asking the opposite of that
i don't want i don't care whether
someone does on the religious umbrella
or not i really want to
try to really hone in on the distinction
between a pure physicalist such as
myself who says look
uh i'm a complex creature biological
organism
i have evolved i have certain impulses
certain instincts
i also have higher cognitive capacities
and i can sort of
be a moral philosopher and try to sort
of systematize my moral influences
into an idea about what is right and
wrong
purpose and meaning in my life that's a
view one can have on the fundamental
nature of reality
and our place in it there's another one
that
adds to that view that there is
something non-physical
and important about the world this
transcendent realm this this
thing that we strive for and i don't see
what the difference in my behavior going
through the day
is if i believe one of those versus the
other oh that's a really good question
um so let me put it in two ways number
one i would say the difference between
you and me and i don't mean this as a
judgment or whatever
is that you're inside of a box and you
have
full capabilities in that box high
capabilities in that box
and i have gone outside of the box
and i have said from an experiential
place not a
rational place from a place of emotion
and experience
sean there's something beyond this box
i've touched it i've felt it and in
doing so
i have a different perspective on what
it means to be human
come outside of the box with me you know
touch this thing
how would it change behavior
it's not that it would change morality i
i reject that completely and by the way
that's not just my personal opinion the
pew forum on religion and public life
has consistently done uh surveys
on uh moral views
of quote-unquote religious communities
in the in america
and every year in every question on
every topic atheists are the most moral
community in the united states and i
mean on
every topic every question every year so
this isn't
about morality but i do think that
when your perspective when your
worldview
has expanded beyond the box you can't
look at the box in the same way anymore
you you feel an affinity with
individuals inside that box
you feel a sort of common purpose
in the in of what like the human
condition is about
that is different it so it doesn't
change your behavior
i don't think it doesn't change your
morality
i don't think but it does change your
world view
and that is important yeah no okay good
that is important that's exactly
what i was looking for um uh you know it
it
i can see how that particular set of
beliefs would help
orient one in terms of the meaning of
their life not to put it into grandiose
terms but what what our goals are as we
live our lives so
like you say maybe not right or wrong
but you know how should i think about
myself here embedded in the world
therefore since since good since we've
landed on a
difference between these two views now i
want to think hard about which one i
should
accept so what if let's just say
hypothetically someone were skeptical of
your view
that there is this other aspect of
reality
um and you said well you know look i've
seen outside the box
and and they said to you actually you're
still right there
you've imagined you're seeing outside
the box but all the seeing was done by
stuff in the box and there's really
nothing outside the box
how do we judge between these two things
what is the evidence we collect pro or
con
well this is what's so great is it goes
right back to where we started which is
my refusal to accept the simple
dichotomies of material and spiritual
uh of you know uh physical and spiritual
things like that
um a more sophisticated
uh how do you know would be um
no no you didn't you didn't look outside
of the box
um your brain
you know fired off certain chemical
reactions
chemical reactions that by the way i
could um
repeat in a lab if you wanted to i could
stimulate
certain parts of your brain and make you
think you're outside of the box
you weren't really outside of the box
just think you were outside of your box
because your brain tricked you into
thinking you're outside of the box
see that's the problem right there of
course
my brain told me i was outside of the
box
the chemical reactions that happen in my
brain are the only
experiences that i have ever had period
every experience ever ever of the
material
or the non-material rain realm that i
have ever had
is just the result of chemic
electrochemical reactions
in my brain nothing exists
that doesn't happen inside my brain
so that's not a good argument in fact on
the contrary it's my argument my
argument is
yeah that's right i tapped in to that
part of my brain
that helped me experience outside of
this box and you should too
in fact not only should you but you must
because your brain was designed
to do this and you're not doing it
you know so so i mean
i got it now i got to be my physicist
self just
not as even as an argument but just as a
clarification of how you think
this works you know i just finished uh
writing a paper for the journalists
for the journal of consciousness studies
uh in response to philip gough who is a
former mindscape guest who's a pan
psychist
and he's invited people from different
perspectives to talk about
how they think about consciousness and
my view of consciousness is you know i'm
a physicalist so it's a collective
emerging phenomenon blah blah blah
but what i tried to emphasize in the
paper was look
if you think that there are aspects of
the world
other than the physical either there's a
dilemma that you're going to have to
choose between and it's not that either
one is right or wrong but there's only
two choices
uh aristotle told us this either
you're gonna change the laws of physics
through the influence of those mental
aspects or you're not
because we have laws of physics that
given any configuration of stuff in your
brain
is going to tell you what they're going
to do and
there's no influence in those laws of
physics of anything non-physical
so either you think the laws of physics
aren't quite right because we left out
an important part
or you think that those other aspects
are completely epiphenomenal and just go
along for the ride
do you have those the laws of physics
are incomplete
what kind of arrogant mind would think
that we've got it figured out already i
mean again
yes this is the problem is that it's
back to that dichotomy right so when
you're when you're stuck
in that you know spiritual material
dichotomy
you think to yourself well we don't need
the spiritual because we have
the laws of physics that explain the
material
realm and when someone shows up and says
no what you
call the material realm is missing
something
it's missing something that isn't out
you know isn't separate from you know
the material realm isn't something
that's
out there it's a
means of experiencing the human
condition the means of experiencing
reality that is more
expansive than the five
senses that we are locked in right
so i i completely hear you you're like
wait but
then we'll have to rewrite the laws of
physics damn right we have to rewrite
the laws of physics
the more the more we expand our
understanding of the universe the more
we're going to have to change
you know the frameworks around which we
the frameworks we use to explain it
so you think in other words and so so
i'm just to get i don't be too
coy about it here uh my view is
no we're not going to change the laws of
physics the laws of physics are
incomplete there's plenty of things we
don't understand
but as my longtime listeners know the
laws of physics that are required to
explain what's going on in your brain
are 100 super duper understood there's
no room for them to be changed without
violating all sorts of experimental
data now i mean of course you can
imagine things uh
but the realm that we think we have
confidence in extends perfectly well to
everything going on in human brains and
bodies
so just to so i'm not going to have an
argument we don't need to we can argue
about that if you want but
that's not what i'm trying to get to
what i'm trying to get to is you think
just to be super duper clear that when
you
uh express when you give testimony about
having
uh had some transcendent experience or
or um uh thought about
the you know the spiritual realm of
things
there are neurons in your brain that uh
are
telling your mouth or your hands to make
those noises and express those thoughts
and those neurons are in some sense
being pushed around
the electrons and the atoms in those
neurons are being pushed around
by something outside the laws of physics
or have been at some point
no i yeah no i i don't know if i would
put it as
uh they're being pushed around by
something outside the laws of physics
what i'm saying the known laws of
physics yeah the
okay yes what i would say is that the
the laws that we rely on
explain the workings of the universe
and indeed the workings of you know the
the brain and consciousness and all that
that those laws
are as incomplete do not
uh necessarily take they're not
cognizant of the
abilities that our brains
have the cognitive abilities that they
have
to experience things beyond the material
realm to experience
transcendence i don't think but again
should they i mean do they by definition
you know is is that something that the
well no i would say yes so forget about
that part yes i would say yes they
should
they should they should because again i
don't wanna i don't wanna create this
sort of separation
i don't wanna say that that what is the
experience of transcendence that i have
is something unique that only i can do
or it means that i have tapped into
something outside of myself
no the experience of transcendence that
i have had
are the normal workings
of my cognitive processes that i have
accessed and made use of
in a way that everyone can and does
and and some people don't or
choose not to good and i think this has
been very good i mean
you've been very helpful in sort of
articulating a particular
view which you know i still want to
think is is just like you're
almost there you're almost an atheist
you know you're almost there sean you're
work on yourself
[Laughter]
right exactly this is what people are
going to say to each other but i mean
some people are nowhere close to being
there so that there is a difference
um the but but then
so for the how i want to sort of
conclude the conversation is
uh again more practical issues i mean as
you said in which i
agree you know there's a lot of
flexibility in the vocabulary that we
use about these things god and religion
etc
religion in particular um is far more
than just a view of the ultimate nature
of reality it's a set of communal
practices
a set of ideas about right and wrong or
whatever um
and and so the choice has to be made
when you're someone who is
like you you know um not a
uh an answer a believer in an
anthropomorphic kind of god right
guy up there on the throne with a beard
giving us instructions
i mean you could choose to
adopt the spiritual but not religious
kind of label right you just say i'm not
muslim i'm not religious i believe in
this transcendent realm but you've made
a choice
uh to identify yourself as muslim
and so i want to know like why that's a
good choice
in your point of view and i so i have
arguments that it's a bad choice but why
don't you tell us why it's a good choice
first
no it's a really good point um
you know uh it does go back to that
thing where
okay so let's say you're somebody who uh
is spiritual uh wants to experience
transcendence strives to experience
transcendence i would say that there are
two ways
of expressing that emotion
one is the sort of monastic way of doing
so
where it's all deeply internalized
um you know it's all uh
a part of how you understand the world
and your place
in it but it's personal as
individualistic
it's your business but let's say you
want to talk about it
yeah which people let's say you want to
just even express it
in words i mean just if anyone listened
to the last 50 minutes of this
conversation they would be like what the
[ __ ] are you guys talking about
you know like what is it like
transcendence and neurological
phenomenon and uh like
people you can't communicate what what
i am trying to express a picture of that
in these words exactly um
i do want to communicate it i want a
community
i want to be able to commune with
others who have had similar experiences
and i want to be able to express
in human terms what that feeling was
like
i don't know how to do it i really don't
know how to do it
i can rely on symbols and metaphors
because that's all that that's available
to me
so i have to use you know symbolic
metaphorical language
now i could come up with my own symbolic
metaphorical language
it would help me understand it but if
you don't speak that language how would
i communicate it to you
you know and so i want
to communicate it and so i know a
language
i have this language in my case it's
it's
islam that allows me
to express what is fundamentally
inexpressible
and allows others who speak that
language
to understand what i'm trying to say and
then
uh and to feel it when i give when i
give lectures
on this topic i i do this experiment
sometimes and this might
you know work with your listeners or
maybe it won't but we'll see
but i say to them uh
what if i said i have been washed by the
blood of the lamb
and then i ask people raise your hand if
you know what i'm talking about
and usually about half the audience yeah
raises their hand
and i say raise your hand if you have no
idea what i'm talking about and the
other half raises their hand
the audience the the hafta has no idea
what the hell i'm talking about
heard me just say that what you took a
bath in lamb's blood like what the hell
are you talking about
um because they don't understand the
metaphor
but that the half that does understand
the metaphor
because it's a christian metaphor it's
an evangelical protestant christian
conception of being born again
being saved that half
and i not only do they understand me
but we shared an intimacy that is
impossible
to to fake you know or to recreate in
other circumstances
why because we share the metaphor and so
we had this instant intimate bond
that allowed us to communicate at a
completely different level
you know we call it a non-material level
if you want to but at a completely
different level
that's why that's the why
why do i somebody who has studied the
world's religions and who knows
what [ __ ] most of religion actually
is okay
why do i choose a religion that's why
because i want to be able to express it
i want to be able to have a moment in
which the person on the other side of me
says
i get you i know what you're saying
because i understand the metaphor
well i do can i just say one last thing
but if if it if you start
to forget that it's a metaphor if your
belief is in the metaphor and not
what the metaphor stands for then you're
doing it wrong and unfortunately that's
what most religion is and that's
not religion's fault that's just the
human condition
right but since humans made up religion
is kind of you know religion's fault
also but but so i get that i i that's a
very clarifying answer also and so let
me just lay on
very quickly uh a version of my worry
for even though i appreciate the answer
you gave there's countervailing aspects
i i i apologize to podcast listeners
who've heard me tell this story before
but i was once at renaissance weekend
you know renaissance weekend like
friends of bill clinton
right so you know like they invite you
there and then you're on all sorts of
panels and things like that you don't
even know before you show up what you're
gonna do
and it's actually it can be fun there's
all different kinds of people so um
they had a sort of after dinner
entertaining panel
about like right and wrong i don't know
who came up with this idea like morality
right
uh so 12 people from the couple hundred
who were there were asked to come up and
share their reflections
i was one of them and due to the
inclinations of the organizers uh there
were 11 religious people and me
and uh explicitly religious people not
like you know just personal monkish
and when it came for the prompting
question that was asked to me
the question was i'd be really
interested to hear
sean what your best argument for
religion
is and i'm like i'm the only atheist up
here
talking about right and wrong and i'm
not allowed to talk about atheism and i
think that this is a reflection of the
fact that
with all the potential helpfulness of a
shared metaphor
there's also obviously potential danger
in
leveraging these views about the
fundamental nature of reality
into pretty strict and not always
correct
rules about living our lives you know as
we're recording this
this week the supreme court came down
with a a ruling that that didn't allow
the city of philadelphia to
um tell catholic social services that
they had to be able to
let gay couples adopt right and the
reasoning is that there is a i mean it's
a narrow
legalistic reasoning but the culture war
is
um that there's religious freedom right
catholic social services
don't believe in giving uh
adoptive children to gay parents so
that's and it's an example where
in in my mind this religious language is
co-opted and
leveraged into a certain kind of
regressive point of view and
to me that danger is bigger
than the benefit you get from a shared
metaphor and here's what i would say to
you
by the way i've got an op-ed on that
supreme court case in the la times
coming out tomorrow i don't know when
this
podcast will be available but it'll be
in the past by the time and it is it is
it is precisely an op-ed you know from
the perspective
of three scholars of religion decrying
the way in which
issues of religious liberty are being
used as a shield
for prejudice and racism
but again there is nothing
rarified about religion in that regard
to blame religion for
acts of prejudice or violence or
you know the negative things that come
from religion
would be akin to blaming
socialism for nazism or communism
for you know or for marxism or marxism
for communism
or or for that matter um
you know blaming science for eugenics
what i keep coming back to is that this
is who we are as human beings
we because we strive for certainty
because we are naturally prejudicial
people
we and because we strive for power
we will use any ideology to control
and to oppress that's just what we
are we will use secularism for that very
same
reason you know i mean i always remind
people that
you know mao killed 10
000 nuns why
simply because he saw religion as a
force for evil that needed to be rooted
out of society
and so he did so by slaughtering you
know religious people
this is just what we do so what you see
as the negative aspects of religion
i see is just what human human reality
and i can use a number of secular
societies
that force secularism
in violent ways uh on people in the same
way that religious societies like saudi
arabia and iran
force religion in violent ways upon
society
but my point is a little bit different
than that my point is not uh
the catholic church is prejudice against
gay people
uh and that's bad that makes religion
bad like okay that is an argument one
could have but
my point is is not that religion is
making people prejudiced
but that we have as a country
we have decided to allow people to be
prejudiced
if they say it's because of their
religion yeah
people will be prejudiced or not
religious people atheists whatever
but we carve out a protected class and
this is exactly what
i worry about even if it's just a
metaphor even it's just a vocabulary
it's
there's plenty of people who don't treat
it as a metaphor and i don't know
sean but but again what you're saying is
that is a that is a a a negative
thing about religion and i'm saying
that's a negative thing about the
[ __ ] constitution
right that the problem isn't religion
the problem is america the problem is
the fact that we have given religion
this elevated position in
in our society but that's not religion's
fault that's not an excuse
that's not a reason why religion is bad
right that's that's that's the argument
that i'm trying to make
uh you know it's
i mean i'm trying to think of another
stupid metaphor for this but you know
the the second amendment right yeah
the problem is our constitution the
problem is
the the the ethos through which this
country was built
and through which it is continuing to be
run the problem
isn't a a machine called a gun
right um the problem is is the the human
condition that
compels us to elevate this weapon
or this means of control um
you know to the place where it's where
it becomes problematic and
and against you know what i've been
saying be before about
against the oppressive to humanity
i love this metaphor this is the best
metaphor i've ever heard on this podcast
in over 150 episodes and so let me
turn it against you and i'll get like my
final pitch and then you'll give your
final pitch
um this is exactly my point that like i
said the
forget about whether religion is bad or
makes people bad i'm not even sure that
it's sensible to give religion the
credit the religion is an abstract
concept right it's people
who are doing these good things and bad
things but words
mean something words have power
metaphors mean something uh
we can not only communicate but we can
persuade we can get people on our side
through the use of a
friendly uh metaphor that they're happy
with right
um the the the problem is not guns
but guns give people leverage right if
you only used guns
properly it would be fine but guns
open up this possibility to use them
improperly and give people who want to
do bad things a huge amount of power and
therefore
even though it's not guns fault i would
like them to be regulated likewise
it's not religion's fault that people
are prejudiced like i i completely agree
with you as you've said here and
elsewhere
that we take our morality and give it to
religion rather than the other way
around but i think that
religion is an amplifier for some of
those
impulses and what i think is that um
the like i said i'm going to say it
again it it's not
that we that religion makes us do bad
things
it's that religion can be used as an
excuse
for doing the bad things we want to do
and to me it would be better
if we just all faced up to the
fundamental ontology of reality
realize that all of our morality etc was
constructed that we're fallible
that we don't all agree get together in
the public square
hash it out and live happily ever after
no i listen i i i completely agree and
you're you're right
using my metaphor that's a very good way
of thinking about it that religion
amplifies some of the worst
impulses in humanity
historically speaking it also amplifies
some of the best impulses
in humanity including civilization as we
know it
so how do you get one without the other
like you know how can you can you say
well then let's just
rid the world of religion and then we
won't have that amplification
either way but it again it depends on
how you think about the human condition
whether you think we are
naturally you know uh
that we're naturally compelled to do
good or the opposite i tend to be a
little bit more negative about
about that view and so i can't help but
think that
in a world without religion we would
have some other
amplification we would use any other
amplification
including science including secularism
including atheism because i can give you
many examples mao slaughtered
those nuns in the name of atheism that
doesn't mean atheism is a force for evil
you know uh
we don't need to talk about you know the
the crimes of science but
you understand what i'm what i'm saying
here um
i don't know what we do about you know
the the amplification of bad that
religion gives
without sacrificing the amplification of
good and yes
i would imagine that most of your
audience tends to focus on the bad stuff
but we can't ignore the profound
good that is coming what you just look
at the last
the civil rights movement was a
religious
movement the anti-war movement was a
religious
movement these were movements that were
predicated on the pulpit
um so if we're going to blame religion
for the bad things that come out of
religion let's at the very least
you know maintain some kind of logical
consistency and also praise religion
for the good things that come out of
religion i'm very happy to do that but
um i know i said i was going to give my
final spiel but
but the but all i'm i'm i'm very happy
to give religion credit
you know like like richard dawkins i
love the art
and the and the music right you know
like religion is is responsible for all
sorts of good things in the world and
also
good acts good good you know it uh
it can inspire people to be better than
they would otherwise be
i just don't want to carve out a special
legal place for
people to be allowed to do bad things
because they say it's what their
religion tells them to do yeah i
actually i i've written
a lot about um this carving out the
special place
which i have a problem with too i don't
the idea that we don't tax religions to
me is absurd
the notion that we actually not only not
not only do we not tax religion but that
we give
religion economic incentives to do
in the world what government won't do
is absurd right or whatever we call it
faith-based whatever yeah you know that
that is a
failure um of our very system i i
couldn't i couldn't agree more about
that
um but you know in so far as a
a force in the world
i think the evils of religion
are no greater than the evils of any
other
ideology that that has had a global
footprint
and i've mentioned you know secularism
atheism communism
socialism uh scientism
and the good of religion
is pretty profound
and and much more difficult i think to
um commodify you know in a way that
allows us to sort of just put it on a
balance
um we we notice the bad stuff we don't
pay enough attention to the good stuff
that's all i'll say
and with that i will give you the last
word reza aslan thanks so much for being
on the mindscape podcast
thank you sean thanks for having me
[Music]
you